willkommen zu unserem nächsten fall
schauen nach baden württemberg dort
wurde ein kleines baby abgelegt direkt
zum sterben seit drei jahren suchen die
ermittler dort nach der unbekannten
mutter und jetzt gibt es einen neuen
ermittlungsansatz die ermittler die
greifen dort auf eine neuartige methode
zurück die es möglich macht aufgrund von
gewebe spuren des babys rückschlüsse
darauf zu ziehen wo sich die mutter vor
aufgehalten hat die ergebnisse jetzt
dritter september 2018 in einem
waldstück an der landesstraße
453 zwischen frohnstetten und kaiser
ringen in baden württemberg finden
spaziergänger einen toten säugling
eingewickelt in dieses handtuch verpackt
in eine papiertüte die polizei fahndet
noch immer nach der mutter kann
inzwischen eine spannende spur verfolgen
durch neueste wissenschaftliche methoden
über die universität amsterdam konnte
ein so genanntes isotopen verfahren
gemacht werden man weiß inzwischen dass
die mutter sich vermutlich in meeresnähe
in wärmeren regionen aufgehalten hat und
aber auch vielleicht in früheren
lebensphasen in skandinavien oder in
osteuropa gelebt hat das zuständige
standesamt hatte den jungen damals
lloris genannt sein leichnam liegt auf
dem friedhof in städten über die mutter
weiß man aufgrund eines toxikologischen
gutachtens der babyleiche noch dass sie
drogen und medikamente genommen haben
muss zur klärung des falls der nach wie
vor nicht abgeschlossen ist bittet das
kriminalkommissariat
sigmaringen um die mithilfe der
bevölkerung
insgesamt ist eine belohnung in höhe von
4000 euro für hinweise ausgesetzt wurden
die zur ergreifung der mutter führen wer
hat eine schwangere frau im sommer 2008
zehn im bereich frohnstetten bemerkt die
später kein baby bei sich hatte hinweise
bitte an die kriminalpolizei sigmaringen
unter 07571
und bei uns im studio ist jetzt unser
achtung fahndung expertin dr konstanz
wie schön dass sie bei uns sind gut sie
sind rechtsmedizinerin an der uniklinik
frankfurt seit 25 jahren und dort sind
sozusagen 100 leichen über ihren
schreibtisch gegangen kann man das so
sagen das ist richtig so helfen sie uns
einmal zu verstehen wie sieht ihr
arbeitsalltag aus
wir sind eingeteilt in verschiedene
dienste wir machen also viel mehr sachen
wie in der allgemein bürger
wahrscheinlich meint und wir machen ein
mal pro woche eine sektion dienst da
werden also in der regel drei bis vier
leichen obduziert ansonsten sie mir viel
bei gericht und haben tatsächlich sehr
viel schreibtischarbeit alle sachen
müssen aufgearbeitet werden begutachtet
werden beschrieben werden ja so dass wir
ein sehr buntes arbeitsfeld haben was
die meisten eigentlich wahrscheinlich
gar nicht so wissen wir waren 25 jahre
lang rechtsmedizinerin ist ist man ja
sozusagen ständig mit tod konfrontiert
ich glaube das kann man so sagen macht
das mit ihnen persönlich was haben sie
verhalten geändert in irgendeiner form
in diesen jahren ja man muss natürlich
schnellstmöglich lernen damit umzugehen
und das gelingt dann eigentlich auch
relativ schnell und die erfahrung ist
die kollegen die dabei bleiben die
schaffen das und und die die es nicht
können die sind immer ganz schnell weg
und sie selbst ich weiß nicht achtet man
im verkehr auf bestimmte sachen achtet
man bei der partnerwahl womöglich auf
bestimmte sachen wie ist das im verkehr
beobachtet dass bei mir das ist richtig
also es sind tatsächlich viele
verkehrsunfallopfer die wir obduzieren
die schicksalhaft ums leben gekommen
sind dass man zu dicht an der fahrbahn
steht dass man zur falschen zeit am
falschen ort ist am ende eines staus und
wenn ich am lkw vorbeifahren auf der
autobahn dann bin ich immer froh wenn
ich schnell vorbei bin so das sind so
die sachen im täglichen leben die sich
ändern die partnerwahl
das ist weniger dass es wichtig
erscheint und man muss auf bestimmte
sachen achten dass die leute nicht
provozierten entgeht das schon okay dann
lassen sie uns einmal über diesen fall
der kleine junge brechen und dieses
isotopen verfahren was wir da gehört
haben worum geht es da genau wie
funktioniert das man macht sich also
chemische elemente zu nutze ganz
einfache schwefel sauerstoff wasserstoff
die praktisch die grundbausteine des
lebens sind die nehmen wir alle mit dem
wasser mit der luft mit der nahrung auf
und wir alle haben quasi unser muster
von diesen grundbausteinen die haben die
eigenschaft dass diese elemente kleine
untergruppen haben und die nennt man
isotopen und diese isotope sind in den
unterschiedlichen geografischen regionen
nicht gleich verteilt das heißt man kann
anhand dieses isotopen muss dass die
personen geografischen lokalisationen
zuordnen wann genau kommt sowas kommt
dieses verfahren zum zum einsatz im
rahmen der identitätssuche wenn wir
unbekannte leichen unbekannte
verstorbenen haben geht es zunächst zum
quasi der erste angriff um wen handelt
sich ist es ein mann eine frau wie bei
das lebensalter ungefähre körpergröße
damit spezifischer man bestimmt
vielleicht zum beispiel den zahnstatus
oder die dna und wenn man ihn quasi
diesem ersten angriffen nicht weiter
kommt das wird mit vermissten dateien
abgeglichen häufig kommt es dazu
treffern dann kann man entsprechend
isotopenanalyse zum beispiel anschließen
die über den geografischen
aufenthaltsort des verstorbenen aus
aufschluss geben können also war er zum
beispiel in seiner jugend oder sie und
wo war in der letzten zeit vor
todeseintritt hier ist ja noch ganz
besonders dass es sozusagen das baby ist
über das man informationen über die
mutter bekommt mit der bitte noch um
eine kurze antwort ist dass wir wie
genau funktioniert das wenn man das kurz
beantworten kann
das baby hatte ich selber
isotopenzusammensetzung wie die mutter
weil das natürlich ausschließlich über
die mutter ernährt wird das nimmt keine
eigene nährstoffe auf das atmet nicht
die luft so dass man eben über das baby
die zusammensetzung des babys
informationen über die mutter bekommen
kann
es kommt immer ein bisschen darauf an
welchen
welches gewebe man untersucht und je
nachdem kann man dann eben entsprechend
zeitlich zurückverfolgen wo zum beispiel
der aufenthaltsort gewesen ist von der
entsprechenden person in diese promis
vielen vielen dank für diese einblicke
und vor allem auch danke dass sie zu
unserem achtung verhandlungsteam jetzt
dazu gehören wir werden es bestimmt bald
wiedersehen dankeschön und
das kleine baby jurist das eben vor
genau drei jahren direkt nach der geburt
zu sterben abgelegt wurde die polizei
sucht nach der unbekannten mutter wir
haben es gehört sollten sie also dank
der neuen information hinweise zur
mutter geben können dann wenden sie sich
bitte unter
1040 an die ermittler